I'm Blake this is my wife Courtney and
we're out here in the Upper Peninsula of
Michigan in the middle of summer and it
is freezing out here so we had to come
on inside so currently we're traveling
across the United States in the RV
[Music]
six years ago we were living normal
within a 3,000 square foot home three
car garage filled with cars had our
daughter Nolan
arrived soon after and realized we
couldn't we couldn't keep up like had
lost his job I had decided to stay home
or we had decided for me to stay home
when Hayley was born so we went from two
incomes to one to none and knew we
needed to financially get our house in
order so we took financial peace through
our church and haven't looked back six
months into the Financial Peace
University Blake was diagnosed with
lymphoma and the whole process of paying
off her debt over five years he's had it
reoccur two times so a total of three
times we've battled the cancer and paid
for it cash each time
not only do we get life insurance
through Dave's teachings and financial
piece but we've been given just an
incredible piece to live in the moment
enjoy our family and just enjoy all the
healthy days we have instead of waiting
for retirement to hit the road and live
these dreams we've had the window of
opportunity came and we knew five years
from now we'd regret if we hadn't done
it so home is where we park it for now
getting on a debt and this whole journey
has given us the freedom to dream the
freedom to know that it doesn't just
have to be a dream truly you can live
like no one else it's just a matter of
taking the right steps to get there so
you have that freedom to live in peace
and so finally we became debt-free in
the summer of 2016
well I'd say this whole RV trip actually
started out as a joke a long time ago
when we sold our home and downsize
several times it's kind of our way of
grieving through the process of the life
we knew - the life we were learning and
comedies what got us through a lot of
the hard parts in that journey little
did we know when we started joking about
moving into an RV or getting an RV that
with them truly be living in the RV on
the road and so when we started talking
about the RV dream we said why why can't
we financially we could because of
getting out of debt and so we went ahead
and went for it we're on this get living
adventure we're calling it because we
can we knew going into it it was a
little bit crazy but we've also learned
that normal is boring and we're okay
embracing crazy if that means we get to
be together and have a better quality of
life so there's no magic trust-fund
there's no lotto winnings it's just
regular life and we took it from sticks
and bricks and put it in an RV we still
sit down the first of the month at the
end of the month and do our budget have
same budget we had living in a home
except we're now in an RV so the freedom
and that is we have less outgoing
expenses and are able to experience more
together
the downside is we're all in a really
tiny space having to learn to live and
work together my work that I do is
primarily on email and phone
and so the opportunity a window came up
to come and do this when I'm clock out
at the end of the day I get a walk out
to campsite and to the outdoors which is
fantastic great daddy was today
is our v-day so when we finally made the
decision to go ahead and go on this trip
we had to find a home and so that was a
process in itself we ended up finding
this RV down in Texas and we purchased
it and we started from there on our
adventure and we headed south to the
beach we know we wanted to get to warm
weather so we basically started in Texas
took us a really long time to got at
Texas Texas is very big and we went
across the Gulf Coast into Florida I
think one of the coolest things about
this adventure is a lot of the
unexpected things that we got to do that
weren't on our radar when we set out we
got to see a rocket launch out of Cape
Canaveral run into old college friend on
the beach in Charleston I think a big
thing for me has been the historical
sites along the way seeing Revolutionary
War sites or civil war sites as we've
been teaching our kids on the road
American history it's been great to have
them go to those locations after Florida
we drove up the coast into Georgia we
visited Savannah we also went into South
Carolina and North Carolina visiting
Charleston and Charlotte we then made
our way over to Virginia until
Williamsburg and then eventually up into
Maryland where we actually spent six
weeks in Maryland camp hosting where we
volunteer with the Park Service and they
give us a free site which was great for
the budget and in return we got to stay
there for an extended period of time and
explore the area into Pennsylvania and
Washington DC and Baltimore Philadelphia
we actually even took a day trip into
New York City which we didn't think we
would do on this trip after we left
Maryland we headed north into New York
we went to Niagara Falls and that was
amazing being able to see that place
that we traveled across Canada into the
Lower Peninsula of Michigan and we
visited some state parks and National
Lakeshore in Michigan places and now
that brings us up here into the Upper
Peninsula of Michigan and we have to
start making our way back home
unfortunately back to Colorado
we're gonna go basically up through
Minnesota and the North Dakota and then
down into Colorado there's no guarantees
in life so we just need to do this while
we can and having that window where he
was able to work from the road and the
kids were able to learn do school on the
road
we just knew five years from now if we
didn't do this crazy thing and truly
live like no one else and we would
always regret not having done it I
imagine there's some people that maybe
look at our story here and find it kind
of whimsical but there was a lot of
planning that went into it and I I think
it only happened because we got out of
debt I can't imagine trying to do this
still in debt it'd be stressful so the
fact that we have that financial freedom
makes it enjoyable we're not
millionaires we make a regular income
we're a young family like we live on
very little but when you have a budget
you can stretch a little a long way for
the sake of having memories for the rest
of your life
as we wrap up this good living adventure
and make our way back to Denver we're
actually gonna be living in the RV for
two months and then after that we're not
sure what we're gonna do the adventure
might still continue excited for the
journey ahead whatever that might look
like whether it's sticks and bricks or
this adventure continues to be
determined
[Music]
you
[Music]